so willkommen zur heutigen sitzung jetzt
wollen wir uns noch mal ein bisschen mit
diesen netten herren hier beschäftigen
sind sie mal ging es ein bisschen
schnell und wollen heute noch ein
bisschen auf den kontext eingehen in dem
albert einstein sein ganz berühmte
relativitätstheorie entwickelt hat und
dann wollen wir in der zweiten hälfte
übergehen zu immanuel kant also wir
machen jetzt ein einschub mit einstein
weil eben das sich so anbietet wenn wir
ihn auf newton beziehen und gehen aber
wieder sagen die in den zeitlauf hinein
also wir gehen wieder chronologisch
weiter und machen dann mit immanuel kant
historische okay also ich möchte ihnen
zum verständnis seiner theorie noch mal
ein bisschen was biografisches
präsentieren nämlich aus albert
einsteins erinnerungen er hat er selbst
was drüber geschrieben und ich möchte
das einfach mal vorlesen dass sie so ein
bisschen eindruck gewinnen
in welchen umständen er diese theorie
entwickelt hat und auch unter welchen
vorzeichen unter welchen einschränkungen
das ganze geschehen ist er sagt also
1895 kam ich als 16-jähriger aus italien
nach zürich also davor ware in münchen
gewesen wo er aufs gymnasium gegangen
ist das hat er abgebrochen und davor
wiederum waren in ulm aber nur ganz
kurze zeit da ist er geboren also
nachdem man münchen verlassen hatte und
in italien kurze zeit war kam er nach
zürich zeigt er nachdem ich ohne schulen
ohne lehrer in mailand bei meinen eltern
ein jahr verbracht hatte mein ziel war
die aufnahme ins polytechnikum ohne dass
ich mir darüber klar war wie ich dies
anstellen sollte es war ein
eigenwilliger eigenwillige aber
bescheidener junger mensch der sich
seine lückenhaften einschlägige
kenntnisse in der hauptsache durch
selbststudium erworben hatte gierig nach
tieferen verstehen aber rezept eve wenig
begabt und mit einem schlechten
gedächtnis behaftet erschien mir das
studium keineswegs als eine leichte
aufgabe
mit einem gefühl wohl begründete
unsicherheit meldete ich mich zur
aufnahmeprüfung in die ingenieur
abteilung die prüfung zeigte mir
schmerzlich die lückenhaft ich keine
vorbildung trotzdem die prüfen sind
geduldig und verständnisvoll waren und
wie sollte es anders sein da sich durch
viel empfand ich als voll berechtigen
tröstlich aber war es dass der physiker
weber mir sagen ließ ich dürfe seine
kollegs hören wenn ich in zürich bliebe
der direktor professor herzog aber
empfahlen mich an die kantonsschule in
aarau wo ich nach einjährigem studium
die matur matura abitur bestand diese
schule hat durch ihren liberalen geist
und durch den schlichten ernste auf
keinerlei äußerliche autorität sich
stützen den lehrer einen unvergesslichen
eindruck hinter mir hinterlassen
durch vergleich mit sechs jahren
schulung an einem deutschen autoritär
geführten gymnasium wie in münchen wurde
mir eindringlich bewusst bisher die
erziehung zu freien handeln und
selbstverantwortlichkeit jener erziehung
überlegen ist die sich auf drill
äußerlich autorität und ehrgeiz stützt
echte demokratie ist kein lehrer waren
das hat als 1952 geschrieben die
bewertung müssen wir natürlich noch
vornehmen während dieses jahres und
aarau kamen die frage wenn man einer
lichtwelle mit lichtgeschwindigkeit nach
läuft so würde man einen zeit
unabhängiges wellen feld vor sich haben
so etwas scheint es aber doch nicht zu
geben
dies war das erste kindliche
gedankenexperiment das mit der
speziellen relativitätstheorie zu tun
hat das erfinden ist kein werk logischen
denkens wenn auch das endprodukt an die
logische gestalt gebunden ist und diese
also diese selbstauskunft möchte ich
auch noch mal zum anlass nehmen berg zu
bestärken dass wir als philosophin und
philosophen über solche physikalischen
phänomene reden dürfen weil albert
einstellen auf diese durch geplanten
experimente gekommen ist und
gedankenexperimente sind genuin
philosophische tätigkeiten ja mal denken
wie wäre es wenn man einfach mal auf
etwas für möglich halten auch wenn es
vielleicht nicht wirklich ist einfach
mal so ein bisschen im gedanken herum
experimentieren und da waren doch wie
mir
ein sehr philosophische kopf 1896 bis
1900 studium an der fachlehrer abteilung
des eidgenössischen polytechnikums ich
merkte bald dass ich mich damit zu
begnügen hatte ein mittelmäßiger student
zu sein
um ein guter student zu sein muss man
eine leichtigkeit der auffassung haben
willigkeit seine kräfte auf all das zu
konzentrieren was einem vorgetragen wird
ordnungsliebe um das in den vorlesungen
dargebotene schriftlich aufzuzeichnen
und dann gewissenhaft auszuarbeiten all
diese eigenschaften fehlten mir
gründlich weil sie mit bedauern fest
stellt so lernte ich allmählich mit
einem einigermaßen schlechten gewissen
in frieden zu leben und mit des studiums
so einzurichten wie es meinem
intellektuellen magen und meinen
interessen entsprach einigen vorlesung
folgte ich mit gespanntem interesse
sonst aber schwänzte ich viel und
studierte zu hause die meiste der
theoretischen physik mit heiligem eifer
dies war ansicht gut und diente auch
dazu das schlechte gewissen so wirksam
abzuschwächen
dass das seelische gleichgewicht nicht
irgendwie empfindlich gestört wurde
also doch ganz ehrlich hat ein
schlechtes gewissen gehabt sonst aber
interessierte mich in den studienjahren
die höhere mathematik wenig ärger weise
chinas wird dass dies ein so verzweigtes
gebiet zeit dass man leicht seine ganze
energie in einer entlegenen provinz
davon verschwenden können auch meinte
ich in meiner unschuld dass es für den
physiker genügend elementaren
mathematischen begriffe klar erfasst und
für die anwendung bereit zu haben und
dass der rest für den physiker
unfruchtbaren subtilitäten in für den
physiker unfruchtbar und subtilität
bestehe ein irrtum denn hier es später
mit bedauern 1 die mathematische
begabung war offenbar nicht hinreichend
um mich in stand zu setzen das zentrale
und fundamentale von den peripheren
nicht prinzipiell wichtigem zu
unterscheiden
sowas bescheiden es aber auch für den
menschen meine art von grüblerischen
interesse ist das universitätsstudium
nicht unbedingt segensreich gezwungen so
viele gute sachen zu essen kann man sich
dauernd den appetit und den magen
verderben das lichtlein der heiligen
neugirg andauernd verlöschen
glücklicherweise hat
diese intellektuelle depression nach
glücklicher beendigung des studiums nur
ein jahr angehalten
und jetzt kommt er auf einen freund zu
sprechen das waren studien kamerad der
masse großmann in zürich der danach auch
an der eth professor wurde weil er
nämlich der zweitbeste des jahrgangs war
albert altstadt war der
zweitschlechteste ich komme aber noch
mal drauf ich zeige ich gleich noch das
zeugnis das größte was dieser marcel
großmann ein freund als freund für mich
getan hat war dies etwa ein jahr nach
beendigung des studiums empfangen er
mich mit hilfe seines vaters an den
direktor des schweizerischen patentamts
das damals amt für geistiges eigentum
hieß nach eingehender mündlicher prüfung
hatte halmich dort angestellt dadurch
würde ich 1902 bis 9
in den jahren besten produktiven
schaffens von existenzsorgen befreit
davon ganz abgesehen war die arbeit an
die endgültigen formulierung technische
patente ein wahrer segen für mich und
sie zwangen zu viel zeit im denken bot
auch wichtige anregungen für das
physikalische denken endlich ist ein
praktischer beruf für menschen meiner
art ein segen denn die akademische
laufbahn versetzt einen jungen menschen
in eine art zwangslage wissenschaftliche
schriften in impress iva menge zu
produzieren eine verführung zur
oberflächlichkeit denn nur starke
charaktere zu widerstehen vermögen die
meisten praktischen berufe sind ferne
von solcher art dass ein mensch von
normaler begabung das zu leisten vermag
was von ihm erwartet wird
er ist in seiner bürgerlichen existenz
nicht von besonderen erleuchtungen
abhängig hat der tiefere
wissenschaftliche interessen zu mag es
sich neben seiner pflicht arbeit in
seine lieblings problem mit versenken
die furcht dass seine bemühungen ohne
ergebnis bleiben können braucht ihn
nicht zu betreten und genauso war es mit
albert einstein in diesem patent ab und
jetzt sehen sie mal hier das diplom
zeugnis von sie sehen ein stein ist hier
und das ist die milena marge das war
seine frau und jetzt schauen wir uns
eine endnote schauen sie mal ganz rechts
hier 4,91 also fast mangelhaft
schweizer zeugnis also sechs ist die
beste note aber dennoch ist es nicht
besonders gut was ist das dann für note
vans sechs die beste note ist ungefähr
mit 2,1 oder glaube ich nur zwei also
schlechter als jetzt würde ich jetzt mal
sagen und die milena hatte praktisch mit
36 die beste ist 0 6543 und er hatte
praktisch sonne 2,2 so interpretiere ich
das jetzt meine und sein freund großmann
hier der hier hier
der hatte eine 17 vielleicht so
interpretiere ich das jetzt ne also die
zweitbeste note und dieser hier
ich weiß nicht wie man wie man das den
ziffern hat er hatte so einen 156 die
beste note ist habe ich glaube das ist
ja auch hier das heißt er war der
zweitschlechteste nur seine frau und die
hat auch nicht bestanden
obwohl seine frau in bei den ganzen
rechnungen geholfen hat also bei den
ganzen höheren mathematischen formeln
hat sie ihm geholfen
sie können genau nachschauen also hier
theoretische physik da war natürlich
ziemlich gut aber ich glaube zehn ist
das höchste wie man nicht sicher der
zwölf praktische physik funktionen
theorie astronomie und die diplomarbeit
ware gar nicht gut weil da sehen sie da
haben die höchsten 22 punkte ich nehme
an das ist die beste note war
und da waren auch der zweitschlechteste
also da hat er wohl nicht so viel fleiß
darauf verwendet also hier sehen es ist
naja war also gut aber nicht glänzen im
vordiplom was sie auch im internet sich
ansehen könnt dabei hingegen der
zweitbeste aber zum ende hin seines
studiums hat dann nachgelassen
also so sieht's aus und es deckt sich
mit seiner selbst beschreiben
ja so viel zum biografischen einfach als
hintergrund und was ich damit sagen
möchte warum ich das jetzt bringen ist
sie sehen albert einstein hat obwohl er
nicht der beste war vielleicht auch
nicht die beste begabung hatte im
mathematischen das weiß ich jetzt nicht
oder sich jedenfalls schwer getan hat
damit ein bisschen sei es jetzt aufgrund
von faulheit oder unkonzentriertheit er
hat durch seine gedanken experimente
durch die hat er seine grandiosen
ergebnisse erzielt und eben nicht durch
besonders exzellente mathematische
ausbildung das heißt natürlich nicht
dass man die nicht braucht aber das
entscheidende ist wie mir scheint was
auch aus diesem aus diesem
autobiografischen zeugnissen hervorgehen
dass er einfach sich die
gedankenfreiheit genommen hat und die
dinge mal anders gedacht hat er hat sich
vorgestellt wie wäre es wenn ich einer
lichtwelle hinterher laufen würde mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit
wie sähe das aus dann hätte ich einen
permanenten wellenberg vor mir der sich
gar nicht bewegt relativ gesehen
natürlich ja weil ich genauso schnell
wie er ich bin ein bisschen hinter ihm
eine route die ganze zeit aus meiner
perspektive
das heißt das licht wurde stehen bleiben
die werden ja ja
sicherlich natürlich war der sehr begabt
und so aber eben wie mir scheint in
diesem diesem kritischen denkens diesem
sich nicht mehr regeln regeln
orientieren das war auch so ein
charakterzug
und das hat er natürlich dann der
deutschen dem deutschen schulsystem
vorgeworfen sechs jahre deutscher drill
in münchen
obwohl es ja nicht die preußen waren
sind die bayern aber die frage ist ob er
damit im deutschen system natürlich
gerecht wurde ich glaube es nicht weil
hat auch im deutschen system die ganz
hervorragende ausbildung genossen er war
an einen der besten gymnasien hier
ich glaube das ist im nachhinein auch
ein bisschen verfälscht seiner sicht
oder auch kreativität oder auch genial
itt ja genau der kosten
ja richtig aber eben was mir auch noch
wichtig ist zu betonen ist dass jetzt
diese genialen erkenntnisse von ihm
nicht so zu verstehen sind dass er in
besonders quantitativer weise jetzt
solch eine mathematische begabung hatte
also dass er hier geht es nur sechsen
gehabt hätte und das daraus dann logisch
oder notwendig folgt das dann auch da
eine genial ead sein muss und dass so
eine geniale tät interessanterweise auch
kompatibel ist mit in manchen bereichen
mittelmäßiger leistungen wenn eben auf
einen anderen bereich eine hohe
fähigkeit da ist wie zum beispiel der
theoretischen physik da sieht man ware
immer sehr gut in der theoretischen
physik
die sind jetzt nicht ganz kompatibel
hier bei der theoretischen physik gibt
es nur fünf maximal das war hier wohl
eine andere gewichtung der wurde
theoretische physik bei ihm doppelt
gewichtet wohl so interpretiere ich dass
wir sehen als in manchen dingen ware
wirklich immer durch die bank mit
theoretischer physik das hat ihn so
beeinflusst dass beeindruckt also zu
hause weiter gelesen hat hat manche
dinge vernachlässigt so also es ist
durchaus kompatibel mit nicht immer ganz
exzellenter leistungen sondern was bei
ihm entscheidend war war einfach dieses
widerborstige dieses dieser mut sich mal
in neue szenarien zu denken diese
kreativität diese originalität dieser
diese frechheit und die zeiten ja sein
ganzes leben aus sie haben das gesicht
gesehen wo die zunge rausstreckt er kam
auf tolle ideen dann beim kaffeetrinken
hat er sich überlegt wie kommt dieses
mehr an den von flüssen zu stande diese
komische struktur und hat in seiner
tasse gesehen dass der kleine
mikropartikel sich besonders angeordnet
haben und von da kamen dann wieder auf
eine theorie also hat eben diese
spielerische und das ist glaube ich
etwas was man auch einfach mitnehmen
kann das sollte natürlich keine
anleitung zum zur faulheit seien aber
zum kritischen hinterfragen und zum
andere wege beschreiten durchaus
also ja
wurde meine regel eben gegen die
normalen regeln versuchen zu profilieren
also kann ich nicht von einer anderen
perspektive die bisherigen regeln in ein
ganz neues verhältnis bringen und so und
so hat er gemacht allerdings dass nur
also ein kurzer autobiografische
hintergrund also wie gesagt die
kreativität des gedankenexperiment ist
es entscheidend das machen wir
philosophen und philosophen ständig
darin besteht unsere tätigkeit
insofern haben wir hier eine parallele
jetzt aber zurück zum raumschiff und
hier sehen sie es nochmal also das ist
dieses gedanken beispiel und wie ich
finde es sehr originell und auch
irgendwie kreativ ich will jetzt nicht
noch mal herleiten das entscheidende was
ich es können sie auch noch mal selbst
nachrichten also das entscheidende ist
einfach hier dass das licht von außen
betrachtet also das licht ist jetzt
dieses teilchen was von da unten nach
oben geschossen das wäre hier das
gestrichelte ist die dass dieses
ereignis aus der sicht einer person die
sich im raumschiff befindet wenn sie
sich gleich für mich bewegen dann in
einem raumschiff gleichförmig schnell
und dann von unten teilchen nach oben
fliegt dann sieht es von innen so aus
wie die gestrichelte linie und wenn sie
das amt von außen betrachten wenn das
flanieren vorbei fliegt dann wird
natürlich zu jedem punkt wo der sus
teilchen nach oben fliegt weil sie eine
letzte schritt versetzt und dann
bekommen sie so eine diagonale raus also
von außen betrachtet läuft dieses
lichtteilchen eben eine diagonale und
weil die geschwindigkeit die
lichtgeschwindigkeit eben sowohl im
raumschiff als auch von außen betrachtet
die selbe ist und sie die
geschwindigkeit nicht addieren das ist
das entscheidende
also dieses zeichen wird darin nicht
irgendwie schneller oder so weil es
schon in einem raumschiff ist deswegen
kann man das ganze dann mit dem satz des
pythagoras ausrechnen dass die formel
haben sie zu hause ich will nicht
nochmal nachrichten ganz einfach können
sie das ausrechnen
diese üben sie bekommen
recht wirkliches dreieck der der rechte
winkel ist dann hier also praktisch von
hier bis hier ist der rechte winkel
haben sie hier die hypothese und haben
dann beide male c und haben eben zwei
verschiedene zeiten einmal eine zeit die
diese hypothese mit konstituiert also
die hat die länge 10 x t t ist jetzt die
zeit des äußeren betrachtest und diese
länge hier hat die länge strich also die
zeit die im raumschiff gilt mal weil sie
beide male gleich ist und diese diese
seite hier hat die länge vlt als ev ist
dann die geschwindigkeit mit dem sie das
raumschiff bewegt und dann können sie
einfach nach t strich auflösen ganz
einfach satz des pythagoras alles auf
eine seite bringen ausgaben wurzelziehen
usw
dann bekommen sie eben diese ganz
bekannte formel und anhand dieser formel
sehen sie dann das je schneller sich das
raumschiff bewegt das umso langsamer die
zeit im raumschiff verstrahlte sehen sie
einfach aus dieser form heraus und wenn
das raumschiff sich mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit bewegen würde also
wenn v die bewegungsrichtung gleich c
wäre dann hätten sie im raumschiff aus
dieser formel folgt dass die geschichte
die die zeit 0 würde im raumschiff gar
keine zeit vergehen also wenn sie mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit reisenden vergeht
gar keine zeit
das würde daraus folgen kommilitone hat
mich darauf hingewiesen wenn sie
überlichtgeschwindigkeit hätten dann
würde unter der wurzel was negatives
stehen und dann hätten sie eigentlich
kein defizit definitions bereich oder
irrationale zahlen je nachdem für welche
zahlen bereich sie auf die welchen
zahlen bereits blicken aber dann dann
kommt eine unsinn raus das heißt aus
dieser formel folgt schon eigentlich das
oder können sie erkennen dass sie
überlichtgeschwindigkeit gar nicht
realisieren können
nach diesem beispiel
und das ist ein ziemliches simples
gedanken bei springer belassen einfach
ein photonen lichtteilchen nach oben
fliegen konstanten liegt geschwindigkeit
und das lassen wir dem gleichförmig
bewegten raumschiff geschehen und dann
ergibt sich daraus wenn die
lichtgeschwindigkeit beide male gleich
ne ist von außen betrachten von ihnen
dann ergibt sich dass die zeiten sich
verändert und das ist die relativität
der zeit das ist praktisch dieser ganze
punkt und jetzt bringe ich ihnen hier so
ein schönes flugzeug wissen sie was das
flugzeug ist das hat ein name das ist
also ein typ das ist ein amerikanisches
kampfflugzeug und das ist ein ja aber
ein spezieller her und blackbird ja also
eine art sozusagen blackbird und ein
altes schnellste flugzeug was je
entwickelt wurde und dieses flugzeug
fliegt wissen sie mit welcher
geschwindigkeit das fliegen kann dass es
in diesem flugzeug mit diesem
kampfbomber ist die schnellste jemals
erreicht die geschwindigkeit dem im
continental bereich jetzt erzählt
natürlich sind raumschiffe und
raumsonden noch schneller wenn es ihm
als ich bewegte auf der erde hat man war
dass die schnelligkeit wissen sie wie
viel kilometer pro stunde was schätzen
sie mal wie schnell ist so ein flugzeug
macht drei sogar nach drei und macht
drei sind ungefähr dass das sind 33 1700
km h sagen wir mal sind 3.600 km h dann
sind es nämlich 1 km pro sekunde
dieses flugzeug liegt ein kilometer pro
sekunde zurücklegen
21 und schon sehen sie hier in der stadt
mit 21 und schon drüben
und jetzt können sie mal ausrechnen wenn
sie die formel haben dann setzen sie
eben dass die geschwindigkeit v ist eben
dann 1 km pro sekunde und das müssen sie
dann durch c teile und zählt inhalt 300
tausend kilometer pro sekunde noch ein
bisschen weniger das heißt sie bekommen
ein ganz ganz geringen ganz ganz geringe
größe das ist praktisch fast 0 1 durch
300.000 dieses praktisch gleich null
aber das wird dann davon wo dann die
wurzel genommen und das wird dann von 1
abgezogen und sie können sich vorstellen
dass da von einst so wenig abgezogen
wird also die wurzel von 1 durch 300.000
das ist so wenig dass sie am ende dann
glaube ich eine millionstel sekunde
haben eine millionstel sekunde die in
diesem flugzeug die zeit langsamer geht
eine million zu kommen wenn sie also mit
macht drei fliegen vergeht die zeit eine
millionstel sekunde langsamer vermerken
sie nicht da haben wir gar nicht die
revolutionäre ausstattung um das
wahrzunehmen also aber man kann es
nachweisen und dem cern in diesem genfer
also hier ist das cern das ist dieses
dieser beschleunigungs kreis also ein
riesen radius ich weiß nicht wie viele
kilometer der lang ist aber sie können
mal hier raten das sind bestimmt zwei
kilometer oder so ich weiß das erste
radius ist fünf kilometer das so also
ein riesen radius jedenfalls so sieht es
dann von innen aus also dass so ein
röhre das ist glaube ich 15 meter
durchmesser und da sehen sie dann hier
in der mitte dieses zentrum und hier
wird an der strahl durch geschossen das
sind magnete oder werden praktisch
teilchen ins zentrum magnetisch
gerichtet und dann also durch die
magnete die drum herum sind
und die teilchen werden dann durch die
apparatur drumherum beschleunigt und
können dann eben im umlaufen dieses
riesen unterirdischen radius dieses
kreises geschwindigkeiten erreichen die
die an die lichtgeschwindigkeit
heranreichen
und jetzt hat man eben hier 1977 wurde
am cern laboratorium in genf ein
experiment an subatomaren teilchen
durchgeführt die man millionen
diese winzigen teilchen sind instabil
und zerfallen nach einer
durchschnittlichen zeit von 22 mal 10
hoch minus 6 also millionstel sekunden
das heißt noch 2,2 millionen kleine
sekunde in kleine teilchen kleinere
teilchen
man ließ sie wiederholt auf einer
kreisförmigen bahn mit einem durchmesser
von 14 metern wandern und zwar mit einer
geschwindigkeit von 0,99 94 x der
lichtgeschwindigkeit
lichtgeschwindigkeit also ein bisschen
weniger als die lichtgeschwindigkeit die
messung der durchschnittlichen
lebensdauer dieser millionen ergab dass
sie um 29,3 mal länger war als die
stationäre millionen was genau dem
ergebnis entspricht das anhand der
abgeleiteten form erwartet wurde und
zwar mit einer experimentellen
genauigkeit von einem teil in 2000 also
je schneller sich diese teilchen bewegen
desto langsamer zerfallen sie verglichen
mit teilchen die nicht sich so schnell
gewesen
das heißt sie leben länger sagen die
zeit vergeht langsam bei diesen teilchen
sie altern langsamer weil sie sich fast
mit lichtgeschwindigkeit bewegen
sie sehen aber solche relativistische
effekte bekommen sie nur dann wenn die
geschwindigkeit mit dem teilchen bewegt
werden nahe an die lichtgeschwindigkeit
sind in seiner blackbird zu sitzen mit
macht 3,5 sind also ich glaube ich sogar
noch ein bisschen schneller und sind
black wird ist 4000 km h da haben sie
die millionsten sekunde
bringt gar nichts sie müssen nahe der
lichtgeschwindigkeit seien dann merken
sie sich etwas und das ist halt für uns
praktisch nur schwer erreichbar wobei
natürlich wenn sie jetzt mal schauen
wir bewegen uns ja eigentlich ziemlich
schnell weil die erde dreht sich und die
erde ist wiederum im sonnensystem das
sonnensystem dreht sich und die ganzen
system in denen wir drin sind dreht sich
das dann ganz durch die mit über 3 an
der milchstraße entlang also wenn man es
mal so sieht wegen uns ziemlich schnell
das merken wir halten nicht weil es
relativ ist immer nah aber eigentlich
relativ zu anderen system sind wir
ziemlich schnell
und da ist es noch mal und jetzt kommt
das flugzeug beispiel in einem
gesonderten experimentes 1971
durchgeführt wurde hat man die formel
bei geschwindigkeiten von flugzeug unter
verwendung von atomuhren geprüft von
denen eine in einem flugzeug mitgenommen
wurde und die andere sich auf der erde
befand
wieder wurde eine gute übereinstimmung
mit der theorie gefunden
diese und zahlreiche andere experimente
bestätigen alle die richtigkeit der
formel für die zeit die nation sondern
hat da eben in ein flugzeug eine atomuhr
angetan
zu alt hat man auf einem überflug in
richtung osten als in richtung der
bewegung um circa 40 nanosekunden das
sind 40 milliarden kunden weniger als im
boom ist doch toll oder
das problem ist nur in dieser zeit
bekommt so viel strahlung ab dass die
diese erworbene lebenszeit wieder
vernichtet wird also durch die strahlung
die sieger bekommen leben sie bestimmt
mindestens eine sekunde kürzer
also pech gehabt wenn man das überhaupt
so ausrechnen kann also der gewinn ist
praktisch zu vernachlässigen aber man
kann das nachweisen dass selbst in
solchen tram und ahnen bewegten systemen
dass da die relativität eine rolle
spielt so also ganz praktisch und wenn
es dann um wenn es dann um ganz hoch
präzise systeme gibt die gps und sowas
und satelliten empfangen und so weiter
und so fort da spielt diese relativität
dir sowas von licht eine wichtige rolle
ohne die deren erkenntnisse könnten sie
gar keine satelliten empfang haben mehr
nein also nicht so schnell weil da wären
wir ja langsam aber genau als ist es so
wir drehen uns die sache ist jetzt ganz
kompliziert wird drehen uns ja also
wenn's im flugzeug fliegen dann dreht
sich ja die atmosphäre mit der erde mit
also wenn ich es recht wird das flugzeug
dann beschleunigt weil die
geschwindigkeit dann dass er kein
lichtgeschwindigkeit das flugzeug fliegt
ja ganz normal dann gilt es addition
prinzip wenn es nach osten fliegt er
dreht sich ja dort hinten dann addiert
sich die geschwindigkeit des flugzeugs
zu erdbewegung dazu relativ jetzt
gesehen und wenn es in die andere
richtung fliegen dann scheint das
bisschen langsamer zu sein wenn wir
nicht täusche aber ist eigentlich egal
jedenfalls ist da sind auch wenn sie die
andere richtung fliegen wäre das immer
noch beschleunigt werde es immer noch
eine sehr schnelle geschwindigkeit weil
das flugzeug ja fast 1000 km h hat und
dann würden sie auch weniger altern aber
eben nicht so wenig nicht so so wenig
altern wie jetzt im anderen fall wenn
ich es recht dann stimmt es ja nur auf
derselben geschwindigkeit das werden wir
auch für uns wenn wir uns wenn wir uns
selbst betrachten dann merken wir das
natürlich nicht weil ihr altern objektiv
weniger wichtig genommen
genau das muss man richtig in unserem
eltern genau ja nur wenn sie eben
zwilling haben und der auf der erde ist
dann merken sie eben dann hoppla
ich bin weniger gealtert als der
zwillinge in ihrem eigenen leben
sicherlich genau richtig hier in ihrem
eigenen erleben haben sie eben so und so
viele stunden weil die uhren ja auch
dann an das laufen also man hat ja keine
möglichkeit ist anders zu müssen als im
vergleich ja ja aber natürlich trotzdem
objektiv gesehen wenn sie den vergleich
haben kann ist objektiv die zeit im
raumschiff langsamer genau wenn sie den
vergleich haben genommen wenn sie ein
vergleichs punkt haben wenn sie ihm
sagen können wir haben hier im
verhältnis 1 1 schnellere bewegung sie
ist also viel schneller und je mehr
diese natürlich die erde bewegt sich
auch wiederum das heißt man kann das
wiederum etwas andere messen und dann
ist auch das was auf der erde ist bewegt
und dann geht die zeit da auch langsamer
klar aber in der relation kann man
objektiv sagen in der relation ja also
jemand sehr genau so ist ja genau und
man kann sich das als gar nicht richtig
man fühlt so sagen nicht man fühlt nicht
dass die zeit langsamer vergeht im
raumschiff das füllt man nicht dass also
wenn sie damit weil das ganze denken
dann langsamer geht das merken sie gar
nicht gehirn geht langsam alles geht ja
langsam
ihr könnt ihr sagen es geht ja genau wie
sie merken es eben nicht in der
situation wo es in diesem diesen
gleichförmig bewegten systems
entschieden
[Musik]
richtig dann würde keine zeit vergeben
ja genau das ist also ganz komischer
grenzfall
da bin ich jetzt auch kein experte aber
die formel sagt eben das dann zeitgleich
0 ist oder gegen nur geht
[Musik]
ich mein ich meine was wir natürlich
haben ist so raumsonden und so wenn man
da ziemlich schnell fliegt und so dass
die sind schon ziemlich schnell
ja die fliegen wahnsinnig schnelle aber
halt gemessen an der
lichtgeschwindigkeit sind es auch
vernachlässigbare größe
ich weiß nicht wie schnell eine
raumsonde fliegt im luftleeren raum
ich weiß nicht schon so ein paar hundert
kilometer pro sekunde bestimmt
vielleicht auch tausend kilometer pro
sekunde das scheint jetzt ein bisschen
viel zu sagen ich weiß es nicht aber ein
paar hundert kilometer pro sekunde
bestimmt und da sind aber auch dann
diese relativistische effekte so gering
weil sie müssen das dann durch 300.000
teilen und das praktisch eigentlich noch
ins quadrat nehmen und dann durch
300.000 teilen und dann noch eine wurzel
daraus ziehen davon ziehen und das ist
so gering was dann rauskommt
das ist zu vernachlässigen jetzt hatten
sie noch gemeint
daran wird auch das denken kannst du
nicht geschwindigkeit die würde könnte
man
mehr als alles eben alles wird eben
langsamer verlaufen also nicht nur die
uhren würden langsamer verlaufen sondern
eben auch alle unsere prozesse im gehirn
also alles wäre eben anders getaktet
sozusagen und man würde es ich weiß eben
nicht wie es ist jetzt wenn die band
immer nicht geschwindigkeit erreichen
würde das kann ich müsste man jetzt eine
vermutung anstellen wie das dann wäre
weil dann hätte die zeit ja gar keine
ausdehnung mehr und denken scheint ja so
was wie ausdehnung zu erfordern
man würde also ich weiß es nicht also
man würde sicherlich auch gar nicht
überleben das sind andere punkt also
organismen werden das nicht überleben
beschlossene eine geschwindigkeit von
auf lichtgeschwindigkeit beschleunigt zu
werden das wird ein lebendiges wesen gar
nicht gar nicht überstehen
also es wäre für uns gar nicht möglich
als angenommen es gäbe die möglichkeit
materie also uns so zu beschleunigen
dass irgendwann lichtgeschwindigkeit 1
da werden wir am ende tot das ist so
weil diese diese beschleunigungskräfte
und zerreißen
die würden uns ganz kaputt machen
ja es gibt ja dieses looks tanz das ist
ja dieses jetzt dieses permanente jetzt
so könnte man sie das vielleicht
vorstellt als sie haben eine zeitlose
zeit sie haben ein permanentes jetzt sie
haben keinen verlauf die zeit bewegt
sich nichts tut sich nichts sie ruhen
jetzt so vielleicht könnte man sich
vorstellen als geht am nächsten
es gibt keine zukunft keine
vergangenheit es gibt nur gegen war
genau mit der arbeit zu sprechen
sie haben sie dieses punktes tanz dieses
dieses fixierte jetzt das bewahrte jetzt
mit der arbeit zu sprechen sie haben nur
die gegenwart alles ist gegenwart so
wäre dass sich zu denken
die frage ist halt ob wir es
physikalisch biologisch überleben würden
und das wohl nicht sie kennen ja die
experimente wenn dann so toth soldaten
in solchen zentrifugen dar eingesetzt
werden um so fliehkräfte um zu testen
mit einer bestimmten
beschleunigungskraft werden die
ohnmächtig wenn sie dies haben die
zentrifuge wenn sie da drin sitzen
sondern kapseln die wird so im kreis
beschleunigt und sie müssen sich
überlegen um auf die
lichtgeschwindigkeit gebracht zu werden
was dafür beschleunigungskräfte an an
ihn ersetzen müssen
natürlich könnte man sagen wir lassen es
ganz langsam beschleunigen
aber dann würden sie nicht mehr leben
man hat dann würde es jahrtausende
dauern bis man mit seiner geringen
beschleunigungskraft auf
lichtgeschwindigkeit beschleunigt würde
das ist uns aufgrund der
beschleunigungskraft nicht töten würde
dann wird es vielleicht hunderttausend
ich weiß nicht wie lange dauern haben
würden sich erleben wenn wir das einmal
in einer stunde auf lichtgeschwindigkeit
gebracht werden weil dann müssten es
gigantische beschleunigungskräfte sein
und die würden uns er töten
die teilchen die müssen so schnell darum
herum laufen bisher wie sie das
erreichen das kann man ausrechnen dass
kann mit dem magnetfeld des induktion
also magnetfeld draußen rum und dann
berechnet wie viel energie ein teilchen
aufnimmt pro durchlauf und kann es dann
ausgerechnet das natürlich von der masse
abhängig und jetzt stellen sie mal vor
dass sie selbst in so einem wie alle in
so einem synchron da drin wären das wäre
als eine gigantische energie notwehr
auch die energie die man investieren
müsste um uns drauf zu beschleunigen
wäre gigantisch
ja das ist auch ein guter punkt genau
also die masse wäre auch die energie
wäre gigantisch die man da investieren
würde müsste und diese ja unsere maße
hatten unsere masse und die energie die
aber notwendig wäre wäre auch wahnsinnig
groß
die man investieren müsste um diese
beschleunigung zu erreichen
unter hinweis man kann das jetzt mit
dieser wenn man so ein bisschen anders
und formt kann man diese gleichung die
wir jetzt noch die zeit bezogen haben
auch noch auf den raum beziehen also
auch längen kontraktion gibt es da
natürlich noch und man kann das noch auf
die masse masse beziehen und hat jetzt
ja erstmal nur die zeit drängt aber ist
ein guter punkt okay und jetzt will ich
ihn noch kurz hier zum abschluss hier
noch aus seinem berühmten aufsatz was
zeigen und zwar ist der original aufsatz
der 1905 erschienen und da hat er eben
jetzt diese spezielle
relativitätstheorie grund gelegt und das
kann man jetzt hier sieht man schon dass
der originaltext ich lese mal vor als
überschrieben zu elektro dynamik bewegte
körper von albert einstein ich muss dazu
sagen
der herausgeber dieser zeitschrift hatte
sich das ganz lange überlegt ob er
diesen text überhaupt veröffentlichen
möchte weil dieser text zu revolutionär
war dass er angst hatte dass wenn er den
veröffentlicht und der sich als falsch
herausstellt dass er sich dann blamiert
dass die große angst der herausgeber von
zeitschriften
da sind ja etwas veröffentlichen was
nonsens ist und dieser zeitschrift war
das mal passiert als sie diese energie
erhaltungs satz von diesem herrn meier
kommt glauben also die energie haltung
diesen satz den diesen da hatte er wohl
auch was geschrieben oder andere
jedenfalls energie erhaltung war schon
längere zeit davor und es sollte auch da
eingereicht werden und es wurde nicht
veröffentlicht obwohl es eine tiefe
wahrheit enthielt und jetzt hatte dieser
herausgebe damals zum glück nicht den
fehler gemacht diesen aufsatz abzulehnen
er hat ihn akzeptiert jetzt sagt er ich
lese mal vor weil wir hier jetzt einige
interessante punkte wieder verstehen
jetzt nach dem was wir jetzt hier
bern das ist alles original er sagt dass
die elektro dynamik maxwells dieselbe
wie die selbe gegenwärtig auf gefasst zu
werden pflegt die ihre anwendung auf
bewegte körper zu asymmetrien führt
welche den phänomenen nicht anzuhaften
scheint bekannt man denke zum beispiel
an die elektro dynamische wechselwirkung
zwischen einem magneten und einem leid
hat das beobachtbar
phänomen hängt hier nur ab von der
relativ bewegung von leiter und magnet
werden nach der üblichen auffassung die
beiden fälle dass der eine oder der
andere dieser körper der bewegte sei
streng voneinander zu trennen sind
bewegt sich nämlich der magnet und droht
der leiter so entsteht in der umgebung
des magneten ein elektrisches feld von
gewissen energiewerte welches an den
orten wo sich teile des leiters befinden
einen strom erzeugt gut aber der magnet
und bewegt sich der leiter so entsteht
in der umgebung des magneten kein
elektrisches feld dagegen im leiter
einer elektromagnetischen kraft welche
an sich keine energie entspricht die
aber gleichheit die relativ bewegung in
den beiden finden auge gefassten fällen
vorausgesetzt zu elektrischen strömen
von der selben größe und demselben
verlaufe veranlassung gibt wie im ersten
fall die elektrischen kräfte beispiele
ähnlicher art sowie die misslungene
versuche eine bewegung der erde relativ
zum licht medium zu konstatieren führen
zu der vermutung dass dem begriffe der
absoluten ruhe nicht nur in der mechanik
sind auch in der elektro dynamik keine
eigenschaften erscheinung entsprechend
und dass wir mehr für alle
koordinatensystem welche die
mechanischen gleichung gelten auch die
gleichen elektro dynamischen optischen
gesetze gelten wie dies für die größen
erster ordnung bereits erwiesen ist wir
wollen diese vermutung deren inhalt im
folgenden prinzip der relativität
genannt werden wird zur voraussetzung
erheben und außerdem die mit ihm nur
scheinbar unverträgliche voraussetzungen
einführen da sich das licht im leeren
raum ist stets mit einer bestimmten von
bewegungs zu stellen des emittierenden
körpers unabhängigen geschwindigkeit
fortpflanzen das war das beispiel mit
dieser über die bewegende glühbirne ganz
schnell und die glühbirne strahlt in
bewegungsrichtung natürlich alle
richtungen bewegungsrichtung vertonen
aus mit lichtgeschwindigkeit c dann ist
die geschwindigkeit der photonen in
bewegungsrichtung nicht schneller
aufgrund der bewegten körpern als es ein
lichtstrahl ist hier nicht von einer
bewegten quelle-aus geht aber in die
selbe richtung verläuft als die
geschwindigkeit geschwindigkeit ist
überall gleich auch wenn es sich um
bewegte grünen handel
diese beiden voraussetzungen genügen um
zu einer einfachen und
widerspruchsfreien elektro dynamik
bewegte körper zu gelangen unter
zugrundelegung der max wünschen theorie
für ruhende körper die einführung des
eines licht es wird sich insofern als
überflüssig erweisen als nach der zu
entwickelnden auffassung wieder ein mit
besonderen eigenschaften ausgestattete
absoluter raum eingeführt noch einen
punkt des leeren raumes in welchem
elektromagnetische prozess stattfinden
ein geschwindigkeits sektor zugeordnet
die zu entwickelnde theorie stützt sich
wie jede andere elektro dynamik auf die
kinematik des starren körpers da die
aussagen einer jeden theorie beziehungen
zwischen starren körpern
koordinatensystem uhren und
elektromagnetischen prozessen betreffen
die nicht genügende berücksichtigung
dieses umstandes ist die wurzel der
schwierigkeiten mit den elektro dynamik
bewegter körper gegenwärtig zu kämpfen
hat also auch gegen dieses diesen licht
den äther in dem sich das licht
angeblich bewegen soll
das hat man damals ja angenommen und da
hatte dieses experiment von mike & molly
das experiment um coachees dass ich ihn
ja in der letzten sitzung kurz erklärt
hatte gezeigt dass es eben kein licht
älter gibt weil man damit gerade
beweisen wollte und damit hat man etwas
zu belegen es geradezu widerlegt und das
nennt man im experiment ein kurzes und
jetzt kommt der zentrale satz für unser
seminar hier
wir sehen also dass wir den begriff der
gleichzeitigkeit keine absolute
bedeutung beimessen dürfen sind das zwei
ereignisse werden von einem
koordinatensystem aus betrachtet
gleichzeitig sind von einem relativ zu
diesem system bewegen system aus
betrachtet nicht mehr als gleichzeitige
ereignisse auf zu fassen sind
also das ist dass dieser gedanke von der
absoluten zeit könnte man sagen der wird
hier in frage gestellt das ist wir
müssen das aufgeben dieses prinzip also
da haben sie es im original das ist
jetzt sagen dieser originaltext dann
habe ich auch ins internet gestellt
können sie auch auf wikipedia führen und
jetzt gehen wir noch kurz auf diesen
minkowski raum zu sprechen kommen darauf
zu sprechen kurz wie stellen sie sich
denn jetzt vor können sie das mal
erklären wieso ist es jetzt ein kegel
wir haben jetzt einen titel gibt seine
gegenwerts gegenwart körperfläche hier
sowieso ist es ein kegel
kann das jemand von ihnen erklären
genau also man könnte sich das so
vorstellen
von einem bestimmten punkt aus den wir
jetzt mal fixieren breitet sich das
licht praktisch kugelförmig aus als er
von einem bestimmten punkt kann es sich
nur in lichtgeschwindigkeit alle
richtung wenn wir alle richtungen
ansehen wie seine vision luftballon der
sich vom zentrum her gleichmäßig
ausdehnt und diese gleichmäßig
ausdehnung ist die lichtgeschwindigkeit
so muss man sich das vorstellt seine
bestimmten punkten wie sein luftballon
der wird immer größer der planet sich
schneller auf und zwar diese
geschwindigkeit des aufsehens ist die
lichtgeschwindigkeit in jede richtung
vom radius auf lichtgeschwindigkeit war
wird er grösser ist so praktisch eine
kugel die immer größer sein weil das
licht in alle richtungen hier an einem
bestimmten punkt aus fliegen kann es
gibt also eine kugel und wenn sie die
kugel dann mit ihrer aufblähung bewegung
in der zeit sich vorstellen dann ergibt
sich von der querschnitt gesehen die
kugel wird in der zeit also man
verschiebt die kugel praktisch die immer
grösser wird in der im zeitstrahl dann
ergibt sich auch so ein kegel
so kann man sich das auch erklären und
weil eben die lichtgeschwindigkeit
konstant ist und das teilen sich eben
mit konstanter bewegung also die
geschwindigkeit bewegt ergibt sich hier
eine ganz gerade also eine art eine
linie die nicht grund ist weil sich und
keine beschleunigte bewegung handelt
sondern eine konstante bewegung das
lichtteilchen ergibt sich so ein kegel
jetzt überlegen sie mal was daraus folgt
wenn ich jetzt hier wo der mauszeiger
ist hier kann ich hier ein ereignis
stattfinden lassen
hier kann hier ein ereignis sein ja
genau das hätte sich dann von hier mit
überlichtgeschwindigkeit ausbrechen das
heißt die ich müsste dann diese linie
hierher ziehen und das wäre aber
schneller als sich geschwindigkeit geht
nicht und genauso kann etwas was da drin
ist was alles möglich ist nichts
verursachen was da liegt was hier ist
als dann schneller sein müsste also
kausal ereignisse können sich nur in
diesem titel hier überhaupt vollziehen
das ist dann so eine folgerung ob
kausalität auch an die
lichtgeschwindigkeit gebunden ist also
das ist nochmal hier so eine konsequenz
dieser relativitätstheorie
genau das ist jetzt genau das die
bildung augen halten dass es nun darum
genau wir haben jetzt hier eine dritte
dimension durch die zeit einbezogen die
einige vierte dimension sein müsste der
raum ist ja dreidimensional hier wird
der raum auf zwei dimensionen verkürzt
deswegen war mein vorschlag der dass sie
sich vorstellen
sagen wir so lauter kugel und die werden
immer größer also im sinne dieses
aufklärungs und dass deswegen sind die
zeit kugel und dann haben sie es besser
veranschaulicht weil kugel immer die
dritte dimension haben sie müssten
praktisch nicht diesen kegel so
verstehen als während der kugeln drin
die immer größer werden und je weiter
der kegel auseinandergeht ihnen immer
wieder ausfüllen kugeln dann haben sie
die dritte dimension auch noch drin also
als kugel musste man sich das vorstellen
also sozusagen weil eben von jedem punkt
aus wird den wir betrachten das licht in
alle richtungen ausgewählt werden kann
und weil es in alle richtungen aus
gesendet werden kann mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit ergibt sich eine
kugel sozusagen kugel sphäre die immer
weiter wandert weiter je mehr zeit
verstreicht weil sich in dieser zeit das
licht nach allen seiten die dann eine
kugel definieren gleichmäßig
ausgebreitet hat also die maximale nicht
ausdehnung
natürlich gibt es die geschwindigkeiten
die nicht nicht geschwindigkeiten sind
und das sind dann ereignisse die sich
jeder drinnen vollziehen zb auf diese
rein zeitachse dass wir dann eben etwas
was sie nicht bewegt das wäre dann
einfach hier auf dieser achse wenn sie
etwas weg dann geht es hier eben immer
mehr an diesen rand ran aber dieser rand
dieser trichter rand diese außenhülle
des trichters definiert die maximale
entfernung sozusagen gehzeit zeitpunkt
also ich stelle mir das so vor wie so
kugeln die sie da rein füllen und jede
kugel die kugel die sich aufbläht weil
das licht ja sich immer weiter
gleichmäßig ausbreitet dann gibt es eine
kugel und wenn sie die kugel in die zeit
legen dann ergibt sich auch so ein
trichter aber und kugelt richtung so zu
sagen ja
ja es gibt ja da kann nämlich jetzt auch
zu wenig aus es gibt ja da die theorie
dass es da zig dimensionen noch gibt die
ist dimensionale strukturen die aber so
klein sind dass man sie gar nicht
erkannt hat bis also ein wicklungen da
sich der raum so einwickelt irgendwie da
sind dann auch alles metaphern die man
dazu gebraucht da kenne ich mich jetzt
zu wenig aus als man geht teilweise
davon aus dass es noch viel mehr
dimensionen gibt glaubt 10 oder so aber
wie man sich die dann ganz konkret
vorstellen soll das ist halt die frage
dies sind die sind jedenfalls wenn es
sie gibt so klein dass man sie bisher
noch nicht wahrnehmen konnte also wir
sind so klein und sie betreffen unsere
lebenswirklichkeit nicht während eben
diese vier dimensionen raumzeit uns
wirklich betreffen
deswegen spricht man auch immer von raum
zeit diagrammen als raumes zeit wird
jetzt nach 1 schon immer zusammen
gebunden und nicht voneinander
betrachtet ja also das noch zum schluss
diesen minkowski raum das ist so eine
konsequenz durch die konstanz der
lichtgeschwindigkeit und sie haben jetzt
gesehen mit so ein bisschen satz des
pythagoras wahl mit kreativen gedanken
experimenten können sie ein bisschen die
grund grundgedanken dieses aufsatzes so
ein bisschen nachvollziehen wird
hier an ich habe wieder ich habe er sich
zu abhängigen sind solche
schwierigkeiten
das ist ein guter punkt man kann
natürlich auch sagen evolutionär man
könnte auch einen schritt weiter gehen
und sagen wir unsere ganzen vorgänge und
so sind evolutionär begrenzt
man muss eben dazu sagen dass man sehr
abstrakt denken kann und sich eben im
denken von körperlichem lösen kann
das ist ebenso lang zum beispiel reine
mathematik wenn man wirklich nur von
fünf mathematischen objekten spricht die
weder ausgedehnt sind noch räumlich noch
zeitlich existieren zb ja aber das wäre
das wäre aber dann ihre äußerliche sache
weil das ist ein kontingent also
zufällig na also es könnte ein anderes
wesen mit einem anderen körper könnte
genau dieselben gedanken haben genau
dieselbe mathematisch operation
vollziehen und wäre nicht auf ihren
körper auf den körper angewiesen und
damit könnte man zeigen dass die
körperliche verfasstheit um philosophie
zu betreiben oder um abstrakte
mathematik zu betreiben unabhängig
also die logischen und irgendein
abstrakten überlegungen sind eben
dadurch nicht gebunden an unseren
körpern weil eben die objekte mit denen
wir zu tun haben weder räumlich noch
zeitlich sind wenn man sagt es gibt sie
aber es gibt argumente dafür dass zahlen
nebenraum und zeitlose obliegt es sind
da sonst so auffassen kann und dann
könnte man sich jedes beliebige
rationale wesen vorstellen mit jeder
beliebigen evolutionsgeschichte die
evolution des maßes oder die evolution
von jupiter was ich ja aber das ist auch
philosophie häufig also philosophien ist
auch zum beispiel jetzt kann den wir
jetzt gleich noch behandelt er sagt auch
uns geht es hier um das reine denken
sozusagen uns geht es nicht um ein
denken was gebunden ist an körperliche
zufälligkeiten oder körperliche
grundausstattung sind wir wollen davon
gerade abstrahieren und das ist das ziel
vieler philosophen nicht alle aber es
ist content tendenz dass man gerade
versucht davon wegzukommen von dem
körper ob das jetzt gut ist es ja das
ist kann versucht das zumindest wir
werden es jetzt gleich sehen ein guter
punkt den sie bringen dass man jetzt mal
kant darauf befragt im anerkannten wir
jetzt gleich lesen
ob das wirklich geht die phänomenologie
das ist eine andere richtung über
philosophie die sagt es geht nicht so
sehen die versuchte zu zeigen dass ihm
alle akte körperlich gebunden sind und
dass wir diese körperlichkeit oder die
leiblichkeit muss man besser gezeigt
sagen also körper ist immer nur so die
außenhülle und der leib ist der beseelte
körper also das beliebte prinzip dass
wir das eben nicht vernachlässigt und
das ist dann eher die position der
phänomenologie ja aber man dürfte das
dann auch nicht so beschreiben dass dann
jeder sein anderes denken hat weil
überlegen sie mal wenn jeder der seine
eigene geschichte hat seine körper
geschichte leid geschichte wenn wir
davon dass dingen abhängig machen dann
würde jeder anders denkende ja
vielleicht auch aber das würde dann im
extremfall bedeutet dass wir gar nicht
mehr zu einer verständigung kommen
und die tatsache dass wir zur
verständigung kommen ist so ein hinweis
darauf dass wir von unserer zufälligen
verfasstheit unserer körper geschichte
abstrahieren können und uns ja aber dann
will wäre das ding auch nur ähnlich und
wir würden zb die einigkeit erzielen
können über bestimmte dinge wie in der
mathematik oder so dass wir könnten nie
beweise machen die verbindlich sind auch
die relativitätstheorie könnte so nicht
absolut akzeptiert werden dann würde
sagen ja aber hier zu meiner
persönlichen körper geschichte sage ich
jetzt sie irgendwie das ist jetzt ein
zehntel weniger ein zehntel mehr so dass
man beweisen kann oder so mathematischen
beweis dass scheint voraussetzen so
etwas wie objektivität gibt obwohl wir
psychologisch gesehen von der größe her
genesen und geltung ist immer ein
unterschied die geltung ist unabhängig
von der genese also ob ich jetzt fünf
stunden brauchen auf den beweis zu
kommen oder den beweis in einem note hat
spielt für die gültigkeit des beweisen
der regel keine rolle und es kann
durchaus sein dass mein körper oder
meine mangelnde intelligenz dazu führt
dass den beweis ist für stunden in
bekommen während eine andere
mathematikerin dessen einer minute
hinbekommt dann hat er einfach besser
das gehirn aber wenn wir das ergebnis
betrachten dann gilt es beide male genau
gleich dann spielt der weg wie ich dahin
kommt bin keine rolle
so sehen es eben viele philosophen dass
es nicht auf den weg ankommt den wir
brauchen um zum ziel zu gelangen und
dass es auch das ziel ankommt das
ergebnis und dass das unabhängig ist von
der genese von den
entstehungsbedingungen die
phänomenologie bestreitet das
tendenziell also insofern sage ich ihnen
gibt es eine position der philosophie
die das versucht aufzunehmen aber die
hat es dann schwer zu weisen
objektivität aufzuzeigen
aber sind wir völlig berechtigte frage
und wir werden es beim anerkannt noch
mal weiter diskutieren
jetzt haben wir zwei meldung habe erst
hier
und wenn sie mal zusammen aufwachsen ja
das heißt wiederum aussieht wissen wir
unterbreiten ihm in den kopf lese
irgendein diesem einem privaten flugzeug
das für die gegenbewegung viel besser
genau oder punkt gutes beispiel als
evolutionär gesehen haben wir können wir
uns nur dreidimensionalen des raums
vorstellen leben in diesem kritischen
raum zum beispiel dass es gekrümmten
raum gibt das ist uns nicht nicht
richtig vorstellbar für uns
meine kenntnis ist veranschaulicht
anhand einer kugel oder an das dreieck
auf eine kugel neben 270 grad
ja und ich 180 grad
180 grad hat es in einer zweite münzen
an wenn der raum im plansoll kritisch
wenn ich aber den raum gekrümmt ansätze
wie einer kugel ergeben sich plötzlich
merken und da kommt unser denken nicht
mehr mit unser konkretes denken gezeigt
ich mir also unsere intuition
das wäre dann unserer evolutionären
ausstattung geschuldet stimmen völlig zu
aber die tatsache dass man kowski und
andere ist geschafft haben das so zu
formalisieren und mathematisch fruchtbar
zu machen ohne es an anschauung zu
binden rein abstrakt mathematisch zeigt
dass wir es eben doch können dass wir
abstrahieren können von unserem körper
wir können uns sondern immer konkret
vorstellen oder richtig sind raus
gewinnen aber mathematischen
physikalisch gibt es alles sind wir
können sogar noch viel höheren
dimensionen rechnen es kommt am ende ein
objektives ergebnis raus über das wir
uns verständigen können auch wenn wir
dann nicht mehr erklären können wie ist
es jetzt genau
50 dimension zu haben hatte macht uns
revolutionäre ausstattung nicht mehr mit
aber unser reines denken kann sie eben
darüber erheben und mit hilfe der
mathematischen symbole und
mathematischen operationen dazu seinen
guten ergebnissen kommen
also es gibt immer diese zwei punkte
einmal diese diese eben intuitive
lebensweltliche durchaus revolutionär
bedingte zugriffs weiß auf die welt und
dann so eine davon abstrakte weise die
eben allein durch symbole oder oder
relationen oder logische operationen
darauf punkte
der frühere damit derzeit die mechanik
durch die veränderungen welche
bewegungen auf damit ist das diskursive
dieser angestoßen
da kommt dann nicht auch aus der nati
noch zur weihnacht und den tierischen
einzelheiten persönlichkeit also nicht
ganz so einfach
die frage ist eben immer wie man jetzt
sinnlichkeit oder auch als raumerfahrung
zeit erfahrungen versteht kann versteht
es ja genau das ist für ihn ganz wichtig
genau er braucht immer noch so einen
letzten rest von erfahren
da kommen wir gleich nach drauf er jetzt
hatten sie noch nicht
ist eine abstraktion das modell wie
gesagt weil hier eben der raum hier nur
zweidimensional aufgefasst wird also der
raum ist hier ja aber wir können damit
eben zu sehr guten verbindlichen
ergebnisse kommen und die sind dann
nicht mehr von unserer anschauen
abhängig als ob wir uns das vorstellen
können jetzt ob wir uns davon einen
eindruck verschaffen können oder ob wir
uns noch im modell fassen können so ist
davon völlig unabhängig wir haben dann
nur noch differentialgleichungen
abstrakte gleichung die beschreiben das
dann und zwar so zuverlässig dass wir
beweisen können dass es so ist ohne
davon ein bild machen zu müssen also die
ganzen formeln und gleichungen sind
völlig bild frey gewissermaßen die da
braucht man gar kein bild mehr dazu in
dieser form sondern sie gehen einfach
auf sie gehen davon aus dass das ist
eben hinweis dafür dass es eben eine
sphäre gibt des denkens die logik zum
beispiel wenn es zum beispiel ganz
abstrakte logischerweise anstellen
können die können sich die nicht mehr
richtig im bild vorstellen das geht
nicht mehr
oder sie müssten es dann runterbrechen
und modellieren wurde den heißt ja auch
immer vereinfachen sowie in diesem fall
aber es geht auf sie können mit reinem
denken dass nicht mal unsere sinne
sinnlichkeit gebunden ist erstaunliches
beweisen und das zeigt eben das ist eine
form dass gerade im denken eben gewisse
evolutionäre bedingungen ausgeklammert
werden können wie unsere intelligenz zum
beispiel jetzt ne wenn man eine gewisse
intelligenz hat oder unsere körpergröße
ja oder die art und weise wie wir
mathematik gelernt haben solche faktoren
fallen dann gar nicht mehr ins gewicht
wenn wir uns an diese regeln halten und
dann inter subjektiv uns kontrollieren
dann können wir das einfach objektiv
begründen und sind nicht mehr angewiesen
zum beispiel auf sinnliche vorstellung
ob jetzt da irgendwie so ein trichter
ist
doch nicht das bekommt keine bedeutung
mehr ist es völlig abstrakt losgelöst
von sinnlicher anschauung sozusagen
immanuel kant und das ist jetzt
vielleicht ein wichtiger punkt zum
übergang immer anerkannt sagt dass das
sind ganz interessante these von ihm
sagt dass mathematisches rechnen und
arithmetik oder auch geometrie er denkt
jetzt noch nicht an dreidimensionalen
geometrie an bedenkt analytische dass
die nur möglich ist durch sinnlichkeit
also durch sinnes anschauen also durch
räumlichkeit und zeitlichkeit geometrie
ist nach cannes nur möglich wenn wir
etwas im raum machen aber der raum wie
er ihn denkt ist nicht der raum wir uns
jetzt hier so lebenswert oder auch
physikalisch begegnet sind der raum ist
ein reiner raum sagt es gibt es wie ein
transzendentaler raum ist eine reine
anschauungs form genauso in der zeit von
der kann zeigt dass wir nur in der zeit
mathematische arithmetisch operation
durchführen können weil wir in der
reinen anschauungs vom derzeit
fortschreiben er stellt sich
mathematische operationen so vor dass
wir in der zeit etwas etwas hin zu tun
also wie auf einem zeitstrahl uns
bewegen müssen wenn wir zum beispiel
addieren ja und das ist natürlich eine
vorstellung die heute keinem erteilen
würde aber es ist keine empirische zeit
in der wir das nach kanton sind eine
reine zeit- und jetzt kann man sich
fragen diese reine zeit ist dass die
zeit ist es die a3 oder stb
wir wollen es ja wieder beziehen auf
unsere bisher kennen gelernten modelle
und jetzt möchte ich mal kurz ein paar
fragen doch hier formulieren also was
versteht man unter einer trans zentralen
ist tätig so nennt er nämlich diese
theorie innerhalb der raum und zeit zeit
auf konzentrieren behandelt wie
definiert kann die zeit und worin
unterscheidet sich ganz zeitverständnis
von demjenigen bei newton und von
leibnitz das sind also diese fragen und
jetzt gehen wir mal in seine kritik der
reinen vernunft
das ist dieses werk hier
von 1781 auf das kommen wir zu sprechen
und zwar geht es hier um die sogenannte
transzendentale elementar leere
es gibt immer eine methodenlehre bei ihm
und es gibt eine elementare lehre und
die elementar lehre darum geht's jetzt
und darin geht es um die transzendentale
ästhetik jetzt muss man sich natürlich
fragen was ist transzendentale
transzendentale ist bei kant nicht
transzendent transzendentale ist
übersteigt unsere erfahrung das ist
jetzt nicht damit gemeint mit
transzendentalen was ist dran zentral
also es ist die bedingung der
möglichkeit von etwas hier in diesem
fall ist transzendentale ästhetik die
bindung der möglichkeit von wahrnehmung
von raumwahrnehmung und von zeit
wahrnehmung und tanzen tal philosophie
so heißt auch ganz philosophie ist eine
philosophie die sich nicht mit
gegenständen oder objekten in der welt
befasst die wir dann erkennen können als
mit bestimmten gegenstand sondern die
trans sozialphilosoph ried fragt was
muss überhaupt geschehen damit
gegenstände als solche erkenntnis
objekte werden können also wie kommen
überhaupt einen gegenstand zu stande
was ist die bedingung dafür dass
überhaupt gegenstände uns vorliegen
könnte die wir dann erkennen können
häufig nimmt eine philosophie nur an
dass es da gegenstände gibt und die
können wir erkennen subjekt objekt
müssen zusammengebracht werden und kann
geht noch einen schritt weiter und fragt
ja was muss denn er folgt sein oder was
muss denn vorausgesetzt werden damit wir
überhaupt annehmen können dass es in der
welt erkennbare objekte gibt das können
wir doch alles hinterfragen stichwort
skeptizismus es könnte doch sein dass es
gar keine erkennbaren dinge gibt und das
ist eine transparente halten und so viel
also die frage nach der möglichkeit von
gegenständen von erkenntnis überhaupt
und es wird sich zeigen dass die
möglichkeit der erkenntnis von
gegenständen eben von unserer erkenntnis
weise die jetzt aber nicht biologisch
oder evolutionär bedingt ist sondern von
einer bestimmten reinen erkenntnis weise
abhängig ist das ist das entscheidende
und deswegen nimmt man auch kanzler
sowie ein tanz mentalen idealismus auf
eine gewisse weise als er sagt dass eben
die grundstrukturen der wirklichkeit
raumzeit gegenständlichkeit substanz
kausalität dass die nicht einfach
objektiv vorliegen und wir sie dann von
außen erkennen sondern dass diese
strukturen die die realität bestimmen
von unserer subjektiven erkenntnis
abhängig sind aber nicht in dieser weise
das ist jetzt relativ wäre der ein
erkennt dass die andere dass seine
subjektivität meint bei kant nicht
individualität beliebigkeit sondern eben
einen modus der erkenntnis weise eine
grund perspektive könnte man sagen eine
grund perspektive mit der die welt nur
erkannt werden könnten
ja ja mit dem kleinen unterschied dass
die brille nicht nur das rastern würde
und genau die brille müsste eine zauber
brille sein die brille müsste die
gegenstände als gegenstände er ist auch
erscheinen lassen
das ist genau genau
genau also kannte ist kein absoluter der
idealist das gibt es auch solche
philosophin und philosophen die sagen
wir die subjekte erkenntnis wir
produzieren alles wir produzieren den
tisch wir erzeugen so ein
konstruktivismus wir konstruieren ganz
ganz ganz raum hier das alles die ecke
existenz dieses raumes verdankt sich
unsere erkenntnisse soweit geht kann
nicht er sagt wir brauchen wie sie
richtig sagen ist und anstoß von außen
wir brauchen sind es daten zum beispiel
grün und rot und sowas und hart und so
was solche qualitäten wie
sinneseindrücke können wir selbst nicht
hervorbringen
die können wir nicht erzeugen die müssen
uns von außen gegeben sein
aber was wir machen als trans zentrales
objekte und nicht als individuum als
allgemeine erkenntnis objekte ist dass
wir diese sinnes daten formen also alle
form dass zb die substanz ist dass das
ein pult ist was bestimmte eigenschaften
hat dass ich so davon sprechen kann
das verdankt sich meiner trans and arlen
erkenntnis oder dass ich sagen kann
etwas war früher etwas war später auch
das verdankt sich meiner trans zentralen
struktur die mich der rhein an chance
form derzeit genauso der raum genauso
wenig von kausalität dreht das sind
alles formen und keine gegenstimme und
auf das kommen wir jetzt gleich zu
sprechen also als faktor hier gehen wir
mitten rein auf welche art und durch
welchen mitteln sich auch immer eine
erkenntnis auf gegenstände beziehen mag
so ist doch diejenige wodurch sie sich
auf dieselbe unmittelbar bezieht und
worauf alles denkt als mit abdeckt die
anschauen
diese findet aber nur statt sofern uns
der gegenstand gegeben wird dieses aber
ist wiederum uns menschen wenigstens nur
dadurch möglich dass er das gemüt auf
gewisse weise offiziere die fähigkeit
rezept ivi tät vorstellungen durch die
art wir von gegenständen appliziert
werden zu bekommen heißt sinnlichkeit
vermittelt der sinnlichkeit also werden
uns gegen ständige geben und sie allein
liefert uns anschauen
durch den verstand aber werden sie
gedacht und von ihm entspringen begriffe
alles denkt aber muss sich
es sei geradezu oder im umschweife
vermittelt gewisser merkmal zuletzt auf
anschauen
mithin bei uns auf sinnlichkeit beziehen
weil uns auf andere weise kein
gegenstand gegeben werden kann
also wer spricht hier von einer
rezeptiven hier und die rezepte wie thet
ist die sinnlichkeit also sinnlichkeit
wird jetzt anders verstanden
sinnlichkeit wird heute sehr erotisch
verstanden das ist jetzt hier nicht nur
gemeint also sinnlichkeit ist im
heutigen sinne viel enger als es damals
war damals ist sinnlichkeit diesen
sprachgebrauch einfach alles was mit
unserem sinnesorgan zu tun also was wir
hören akustische eindrücke visuelle
eindrücke geruchs eindruck usw
wahrnehmung ja genau das geht in diese
richtung genommen
alles was wir wahrnehmen können also wir
haben in der erkenntnis immer zwei
seiten nach kant wir haben ein
rezeptiven oder passiven teil
das ist unsere wahrnehmung und es muss
etwas gegeben sein sinneseindruck
akustische eindruck was auch immer
visuell usw
und es geht noch um spontaneität
als rezept das ist das was uns gegeben
wird was wir nicht in der hand haben und
es geht um spontaneität um etwas was von
uns ausgeht was wir in die welt bringen
und das hat einmal mit unserer freiheit
zu tun nach kant vollzieht sie
erkenntnis immer im zusammenspiel von
rezept ivi tät von sinneswahrnehmung und
von spontaneität von sinnes form also
spontanität ist es was den trans and
arlen idealismus bekannt ausmacht dass
wir eben bestimmte formen in die welt
hinein bringen damit wir es mit
gegenständen zu tun haben die wir
erkennen können
[Musik]
könnte man sagen ja anschauen ist jetzt
bei ihm ein verengter begriff anschauen
ist vom begriff her etwas was eigentlich
mit visuellen dingen zu tun hat ich kann
etwas visuell anschauen aber anschauen
darf nicht nur auf sexuelle bezogen
werden zum anschauen muss all das wenige
genannt werden was wir rezipieren
wahrnehmen können also wahrnehmung wäre
wohl besser genau alles was ziemlich
rezipiert wahrgenommen werden kann
das nennt er an schau als anschauen ist
bei ihm eine verengung anschauen
suggeriert erst mal dass es nur was ist
was man an blicken kann also etwas
visuelles wir meinen damit aber auch
akustisch und alle möglichen anderen
sinnes eindruck alles was uns unsere
sinne vermitteln kann die wirkung eines
gegenstandes auf die vorstellungs
fähigkeit zu fällen mir von dem zehn
offizieren werden offizieren ist wieder
die passive seite ist empfindung
diejenige anschauen welche sich auf den
gegenstand durch empfindung bezieht
heißt empirisch der unbestimmte
gegenstand einer empirischen anschauung
heißt erscheinung in der erscheinung
nämlich das was die empfindung
korrespondiert die materie derselben da
sie nicht aber welches macht das die man
das mannigfaltige der erscheinung in
gewissen verhältnisse geordnet werden
kann nenne ich die form deren
erscheinung ist jetzt ganz wichtig diese
gewisse verhältnisse da das worin sich
die empfindungen allein ordnen und
gewisse form gestellt werden können
nicht selbst wiederum empfindung sein
kann
so ist uns zwar die materie aller
erscheinungen nur ab post terror iab
austria heißt durch alle erfahrung vom
späteren her also ist wenn wir
erfahrungen gemacht haben das sind wir
abhängig von den äußeren sind es daten
gegeben die form der see aber musste ihn
insgesamt im gemüt das ist praktisch die
trans zentrale struktur der
subjektivität apriori also vor alle
erfahrungen zugrunde liegen und daher
abgesondert vor aller empfindung können
betrachtet werden also es gibt die
materie unserer erkenntnis das ist
dasjenige was wir nur
wahrnehmen können wenn es uns gegeben
ist dann sind wir abhängig da sind wir
rezepte es muss einen sinnes eindruck
auf uns einströmen wir selbst können
nicht rot rot sind es daten erzeugen
wir können etwas rotes vorstellen aber
im stillen müssen bevor
sagen sie mal ich will was rotes 10 wie
können wir erreichen da sie etwas sehen
was müssen sie dazu machen und sagen ich
möchte jetzt die rot wahrnehmen haben
dann können sie nicht den finger
schnipsen sagen so jetzt möchte ich hier
rot rot haben willst dich hier von augen
zu müssen müssen sie machen
sie müssen zb zu einem roten gegenstand
gehen hier zudem feuermelder und die
ganze anschauen dann haben sie in rot an
druck also müssen sie was machen müssen
sie eine sinneserfahrung machen sie
können die nicht sie könnte dieses rot
nicht selbst hier produzieren
das muss ihm gegeben sein und dann
nichts rotes gegeben ist dann kriegen
sie das nicht vor augen sie können sie
etwas rotes vorstellen als eine
vorstellung aber wahrnehmen können sie
nur was rotes werden sie da hingehen und
das ist diese diese rezepte wie thetis
aproz theorie also immer nur durch
erfahrung muss dahin gehen wenn ich
diese empfindung haben möchte aber jetzt
gibt es neben dieser materie das nennt
der materie auch noch die form dieser
erscheinung und die sagt jetzt kennt die
ist apriori also zum beispiel dass
dieses ding räumlich ist das interessant
das erkannt dass es räumlich ist der
feuermelder das hängt von mir ab das rot
ist nicht also dass das räumlich
ausgedehnt ist nicht wie es räumlich
ausgedehnten ist das nicht aber das ist
freue mich ausgedehnt ist das hängt von
meiner form ab als erkenntnis zu blick
[Musik]
ja das nicht warten bis eine spannende
sache also
wie auch immer es war dann interpretiert
wird das könnte noch offen lassen
dass es aber irgendwie eine
sinneseindruck ist das ist offen man
spricht hier nicht von roth wahrnehmen
das könnte auch bei rot grün blindheit
und so war es gibt ja bei männern häufig
seine blindheit
das ist ganz interessant aber dass da
irgendwas als farblich wahrgenommen wird
das ist außer frage und das können wir
nicht selbst hervor
da muss ich da hingehen kann auch sagen
blau ich sehe jetzt der blauen wie es
interpretiert aber das ist eine farbe
ist ja aber das ist räumlich ist dass
das ding räumlich ausgedehnt ist das
erkannt hängt mit meiner art prior
ischen erkenntnis bedingungen zustande
das ist nichts was uns von außen gegeben
wird und das ist erst mal konto intuitiv
weil wir denken würden wieso der raum
wird uns auch gegeben uns wird
räumliches gegeben
wir sehen räumlich ist hier das ist
räumlich das ist grün oder dieses
geringer ist rothe räumlich ein rotes
räumliches objekt und das kann sagt nein
halt diese eigenschaften rot und
räumlich sie nicht auf derselben ebene
das etwas räumlich ist ist noch viel
besser als das ist brot ist und da ist
was dran weil wenn ich zum beispiel
sagen dieser feuermelder ist roth von
der sat struktur sage ich ein subjekt
der feuermelder und er bekommt ein
prädikat ist rot also das subjekt der
feuermelder ist die substanz und
theologisch gesprochen die einen aktie
dance hat eine eigenschaft und
substanzen akzidenz verhalten sich nicht
auf derselben ebene jetzt könnte ich
natürlich sagen der feuermelder ist
ausgedehnt würde ich damit vielleicht
auch nur ausgedehnt hat wie möglichkeit
die rote farbe zu grunde liegen aber das
stimmt natürlich so nicht weil damit ich
überhaupt von feuermeldern sprechen kann
muss sich voraussetzen dass er schon
ausgedehnt ist in dem ich das subjekt
sätze oder die substanz setzte gehe ich
schon die bedingung der räumlichkeit mit
ein
ich kann mir gegenstände gar nicht
vorstellen wenn sie nicht ausgedehnt
sind in der welt ich gehe natürlich
können zahlen können natürlich kann man
darüber diskutieren zahlen können auch
gegenstände seien die zahl 5 und ist
natürlich nicht ausgedient ist natürlich
auch nicht heimlich aber das ist zu spät
ich nenne alle vorstellungen rhein im
trans and arlen verstande in denen
nichts was die empfindung gehört
angetroffen wird die nach wird die reine
form sinnliche anschauung überhaupt
einen gemüter apriori angetroffen werden
worin alles mannigfaltige der
erscheinung in gewissen verhältnissen
angeschaut wird diese reine form der
sinnlichkeit wird auch silber reine
anschauung heißen gibt es also eine
reine form davon so wenn ich von der
vorstellung eines körpers das was der
verstand davon denkt als substanz kraft
teilbarkeit im gleichen was davon zu
empfindung gehört als
undurchdringlichkeit härte farbe usw
besondere so bleibt mir aus dieser
empirischen anschauen noch etwas übrig
nämlich ausdehnung und gestalten den
feuermelder nur in seiner ausdehnung und
gestalten also praktisch quadratisch
quadratisch kubisch
diese gehören zur reinen anschauung die
ab morgen auch ohne einen wirklichen
gegenstand der sinne und empfindung als
eine bloße form der sinnlichkeit im
gemüse stattfindet also kant
unterscheide jetzt zwischen zwei formen
der sinnlichkeit
es gibt die materiale sinnlichkeit dazu
zählt ihr sowas wie härte zur empfindung
die undurchdringlichkeit härte farbe
farbe usw
das etwas hart ist kann auch weich sein
das sind haptische sinnes qualitäten
könnte auch sagen sie die koalition ist
qualität waren natürlich war es wäre
noch so eine qualität des feuermelders
die wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht rezipiert
werden kann
ich kann anfassen es hart ich kann da
rein drücken dann ist es war ich mache
ich besser nicht aber ich könnte es wenn
ich da rein drücken plastik aber was
können wir noch von der qualität haben
ich könnte daran riechen würde ich
wahrscheinlich aus etwas staub und die
nase bekommt deswegen mache ich jetzt
könnte auch noch ein geruch h das sind
also die empfindungen
er spricht ich kann aber auch die reine
sinnlichkeit die reine anschauung davon
nehmen und das wäre eben die form die
bloße form
das ist also der punkt geht es jetzt um
die bloße form eine wissenschaft von
allen prinzipien der sinnlichkeit a
priori also die reine form sozusagen
nenne ich die trans zentrale ästhetik
ästhetik heißt die wissenschaft der
wahrnehmung heißt es kritisch
wahrnehmung
es geht also um die formalen strukturen
einer wahrnehmung darum geht es und
nicht jetzt im sinne einer material
ästhetik da und da könnte man jetzt
geruch farbe härte usw fassen es muss
als eine solche wissenschaft geben die
den ersten teil der trans en tal
elementare ausmacht im gegensatz
derjenigen wir jede prinzipien des
freien denkens enthält und trans
zentralen logik genannt wird also kann
sagt es gibt eine transall thale ist
tätig die befasst sich mit unserer
wahrnehmung
und den strukturen den grundstrukturen
unser wahrnehmen und es gibt nicht ran
sind alle logik behandelt die form
unseres denkens wieder trends zentralen
ästhetik werden wir zuerst die seligkeit
isolieren dadurch dass wir alles ab
sondern was der verstand durch seine
begriffe dabei denkt damit nichts als
empirische anschauen übrigbleiben
zweitens werden wir von dieser noch
alles was zu empfindung gehört abtrennen
damit nichts als reine anschaue und die
bloße form der entscheidung scheine
übrig bleiben als die trans zentrale ist
tätig betrifft die bloße form der
erscheinung das für das ist es welches
das einzige ist dass die sinnlichkeit a
priori liefern kann bei dieser
untersuchung wird sich finden dass es
zwei reine formen ziemliche anschauen
als prinzipien der erkenntnis a priori v
aller erkenntnis erfahrung gebe nämlich
raum und zeit mit deren abwägung wir uns
jetzt beschäftigen werden also es gibt
grund struktur unserer wahrnehmung und
die betreffen raum und zeit als raum
zeit ist nicht etwas was uns äußerlich
gegeben ist hier ist zeit und hier ist
raum sondern um überhaupt etwas als
räumlich und zeit können zu können muss
sich schon den raum und die zeit als
grundstrukturen st voraussetzen das ist
etwas was uns nicht direkt geben ist
sondern etwas durch das uns überhaupt
etwas gegeben ist also nicht so dass
dieser feuermelder hier räumlich
vorliegt das natürlich aber er liegt nur
als räumlicher vor weil es schon den
raum gibt indem wir existieren kann
guter punkt völlig richtig erkannt würde
in newton zustimmen das ist eine
absolute raum gibt und der absolute zeit
aber dass diese absolut raum die
absolutheit nicht außer uns existieren
als unabhängig von unserer erfahrung
also bei newton ist es praktisch so als
sei der raum sind großes gefäß in dem
alles drin ist sozusagen
und wir sind auch noch drin sozusagen
das ist das modell beim jugend genauso
die zeit das können uns jetzt schlecht
vorstellen auch die zeit ist bei newton
einig so ein großer raum der aber
gleichmäßig verrinnt kann man sich ganz
schlecht vorstellen ja darum geht wie so
ein riesen gefäß aber kann sagt jetzt
natürlich newton hat recht es gibt eine
absolute zeit es gibt den absoluten raum
aber deren existenz verdankt sich der
trans zentralen erkenntnis also deren
existenz hängt von uns als erkennen den
subjekten ab und damit könnte man sagen
macht kann so eine art synthese von
newton was die objektivität der raum und
zeit von raum zeit anbelangt und die
absolutheit dass der raum überall gleich
ist seit über gleich schnell fließt und
leibnitz der gesagt hatte dass die das
zeit und raum letztendlich effekte sind
von ereignissen die sich da abspielen
also er ist natürlich näher an juden
dran wie mir scheint als leibnitz aber
von leibnitz könnte er so ein
nationalistisches prinzip geerbt haben
ja das glaube ich jetzt nicht also ich
glaube dass ich glaube nicht nein ich
glaube das kann den newton integrieren
möchte mit seinem also möchte ich
absolut seiten absolut raum in die trans
zentrale erkenntnis bedingung einholen
raum und zeit sind nicht etwas was wie
ein gefäß außer uns steht in dem wir uns
befinden sondern raum und zeit sind
etwas was wir apriori vor aller
erfahrung schon voraussetzen müssen
damit überhaupt räumliches und
zeitliches gibt also nach kant würde
newton den fehler machen den raum und
die zeit zuvor gegen stündlichen ohne zu
reflektieren das raum- und zeitlich auf
derselben ebene angesiedelt sind wie
räumliches und zeitliches als raum zeit
muss vor allem gegenständlichkeit sei
und nach kant würden juden den fehler
machen raum und zeit zu vergeben ständen
guter punkt ja das ist eine gute frage
gerade
ja also kann spricht auch nicht vom
menschen also das wäre für ihn ist es
eine berechtigte frage aber kann spricht
nicht von menschen spricht von der
bedingung der möglichkeit von
räumlichkeiten zeitlichkeit er spricht
von dem trans zentralen subjekt spricht
von trans and arlen subjekt das ist
jetzt nicht unbedingt der mensch
also da muss man ein bisschen also
berechtigte frage wie war es jetzt bei
dinosaurier hat und dinosaurier auch
eine reine anschauung von raumer zahl
aber so denkt jetzt kann nicht sein kann
denkt was muss von einem erkenntnis
subjekt und das ist jetzt nicht der
mensch was muss vorausgesetzt werden
damit überhaupt räumlich und zeitlich
erfahren gemacht werden kann
dieser mensch der welt im moment denken
aufbauen kann im fertigen begriffe und
eine folge der anschauung hat und
dadurch die welt nicht nur so war es ein
wahnsinn wenn ich als erscheinung und
was davor war wurde ein anderes denke
ich auch nicht genau also denkt sich den
menschen nicht konkret empirisch
vorstellt sich nicht vor so wie auch
diese frage vorhin betraf sind stellt
sich den menschen sehr abstrakt vor als
somit der bedingung der möglichkeit von
erfahrungen ja aber es trotzdem die
berechtigte frage auf die wir in der
nächsten sitzung weiter eingehen werden
ich habe hier noch ein paar folien sind
nicht mehr allzu viele
die folien finden sie übrigens auf die
lowcost also habe ich darauf gestellt
und dann sehen wir uns wieder in einer
woche